so let's start off with the the solution
itself
so we were
approached by the
european hockey federation and they were
doing a project and for this project
they wanted to have an automatic camera
solution which is basically for both
analysis for sports clubs hockey clubs
field topic clubs and also for
entertainment purposes so just to have a
live stream where people can watch right
now people often need volunteers lots of
them
and instead if you have this automated
you do not need these volunteers and in
general this is a trend in the in the
sports industry
so
entertainment analysis
that's the the main point we want to to
build a solution which is useful for
both entertainment and analysis
requirements
[Music]
first the setup so what we have is we
have two static cameras on the midline
of the field
on the pitch and these film one half of
a
pitch each we try to detect some players
in the ball there we apply some some
rules and some decision making and then
in the end we send commands to a ptz
camera which is a pen tilt zoom camera
so it's automated and then it should
follow the the flow of the game very
nicely
what is important to note here is that
we have everything on premise for now
so
the set of cameras are on premise the
pdz camera is of course also on premise
because it has to film the pitch but
also the there's a local server because
if you're talking about for example full
hd
images
that we want to send in 25 frames per
second we're talking about like 150
megabytes per second that we have to
send per camera so if you want to do
this somewhere in germany or belgium or
in spain where the internet is very
crappy as is we also want to have a live
stream we really cannot do this
uh over
3 or 2 or 1g or the wi-fi so that's why
we chose to have a local server there
it's also for latency purposes in
general which is of course very
important uh if we are talking about we
have the static camera um it processes
the input and then we have to send
commands to the pdz camera we're talking
about like a maximum of 300 milliseconds
delay which we would really like because
otherwise you're always lagging behind
the flow of the game and of course the
accuracy is important and there's always
this interplay between these things
because we have a very
powerful model to always be able to
detect the ball then the model itself
will already have such a high latency or
we need to buy such expensive gpus or
graphic cards that we really cannot
have a
sellable system so
keep those things in mind because the
the latency is very important later on
in the talks well so i'll talk about the
architecture i already mentioned uh a
second ago that we have this these
static cameras as input so we have an
image it flows into our input and
pre-processing step
then we do some decision making so in
the input and pre-processing step we
actually detect the players in the ball
at least we would like to always detect
the players involved and then in the
decision making we have to deal with it
because sometimes you do not detect the
ball and then we have to rely on the the
player detections actually send the
commands and afterwards
we decide well the camera should go here
at least on the field it should go for
example to the goal on the left
and then we have to translate this into
an actual command for the camera which
is on the camera control i will go a bit
deeper into each of these parts
so for the input we have the the static
camera as input
we use opencv video capture to to
get these
and
then we do some some light
pre-processing so we mainly crop and
resize the images we have experimented
before also by using like a different
color scheme because it makes it
sometimes easier to detect the ball
because the the ball is wide
the field the pitch here is green and
the ball can easily get lost in the in
the pitch so we've experimented with for
example different
rgb values but different values and
sometimes makes it easier to detect the
ball that would also be done in the
pre-processing we also use opencv for
that
then we have a queue so we put all these
images into a queue
we use pi mq for that i will get into
that a bit later because we first tried
it with multi-processing cues and we ran
into a bunch of problems
and afterwards
we have these pre-processed images we're
ready to do the detections we use the
yolo models for this we also have an
opencv implementation
the frames are then aggregated all this
information is aggregated because we
have two of the cameras and we want both
cameras as inputs so we have well maybe
we take the ball left but not right but
we detect players on both sides of the
pitch usually
so we have to aggregate those
and then we're ready for the next step
so now we have the player and ball
detections as
accurate as we we hope as we like and
these go into the decision maker so the
decision maker basically does three
steps we produce some secondhand events
so for example instead of just having
the player coordinates we want to know
how many players are in the
penalty area like the
circle i'm not a hockey player myself
and how many are more on the midfield
and stuff like that but also um here we
we
may run some oh actually those are the
features and we use those features in
the event producers so for the features
we mostly use just
python and maybe some numpy and then we
want to detect some events so for
example the ball we identified as an
event because later on in the rules we
say if we detect the ball we generally
just want to focus on or near the ball
however for uh hockey for field hockey
you have these penalty corners
and what happens when you do not when
you just use like the ball and the
players for detections
um we see the ball then when they're
taking a penalty corner the ball is laid
on this white line so you lose it like
there's no way to see it and then we
have to uh yeah use the player
detections and in general we just say
well if we have all the players we just
aim somewhere in the middle of those
players if there's a penalty corner
you're done just filming the the midline
because in general there are like five
or ten players who are all standing in
one blob on the penalty corner area so
the yolo models do not work very well
now you have five very clearly or seven
or ten very clear players on the
midfield so you see like 10 players here
five players there and it just films his
players on the midfield i do not have an
image i've got to include it but it's
quite funny actually so we have to
detect these penalty corners so we just
use some some machine learning models
for that
maybe learn and then
we can actually aim the camera at the
penalty corner area
once we've done that we have this we say
well you have to aim this part of the
field so then it goes into the camera
controller an example that i said before
we use one ptz camera but we have a
testing setup where we actually have
three so also on the other sides of the
of the pitch so we have a yeah you can
use that for more camera angles which is
for both analysis and entertainment of
course nice so we have to translate the
per camera the the field coordinates to
an actual camera command which is
basically like a let long and we also
have to do some speeds or zoom
computation we use estropy and numpy for
that and then via the onvif protocol we
send the actual command to the camera
as i said before latency is important so
what we wanted to do from the very start
is
to monitor this but also for for like
the total latency and for each of the
different tasks that i just mentioned
like the features producing the decision
making everything so
we need to monitor this because if we
just run the application we have no idea
if it's fast or why it's not working
basically because always it's there's
something which makes it not work and we
need to monitor some of the performance
so that's basically like how many
players and how often do we detect the
ball we do that mostly separately just
when we're training the models
and
yeah total running time and most
importantly we need to do this somewhat
automatically
actually fully automatically because if
we have to
read through all the logs every time it
just doesn't work because then well we
tried this in the beginning and we said
well it works very fine i see a 100
millisecond delay
we're doing great let's just continue
and then once we implemented the log and
we actually saw what that's really not
what's happening if you read the
application run for 15 minutes or 30
minutes so there's some importance about
the automatic part here
well how to do logging in python if
you've programmed in python before
you probably use the native logging
module somewhere but there are many
packages here so we set up a list of
requirements
so first we should be able to to write
lines to a file that's like the most
basic part of logging so we have a
logger we define a file path that we
have to
log to and then every time that we have
a new event we write
to the file path as a string the message
now next what we want to do is we need
to be able to automatically parse these
so we actually want to to make it in a
format that's not just like text based
because then we have to parse all these
texts and it's just not very nice
so what we can do is we can just chase
in the file this message and just say
well we'll make it into some sort of
dictionary or json object which we can
then read very easily so instead of just
building it as a string we dump it and
important to note here is that basically
we end up with a file where each line is
a json object which we can then very
easily parse
the next point here is that if you've
worked with json before you know that
many of the objects that are in python
cannot actually be
outputted to json so we have to encode
these so we we build a
missing yeah we built like a adjacent
encoder which
does this job for us so for example the
date time is easily formatted into a
certain string formatting numpy arrays
as well
and
the
window is one of our own classes which
is like a frame where we have all these
player coordinates so we have to be able
to parse that as well
then this part is the same but instead
of just saying okay we we lock the
message as is it for each of the values
in this object in the dictionary object
it applies the class above
and lastly
it should be non-blocking we do not want
the full application to run into some
error because the logging module is
actually not working so what we do is we
just start a different process for it
and then we have in a separate process
we log all these things so basically
when when somewhere in the application
we say we want to log something we'll
just put it into a queue and then the
the logger the data logger will work
so these are like the four requirements
and during the
the setting of
thinking or conceptualizing these
requirements we already wrote most of
the code
so
we could say well
we can use one of those packages but
actually we've already pretty much built
it ourselves so this is also something
that we noticed
you can use packages generally it's good
but if it's very simple
you can maybe just you make it yourself
is it the the only way to do this
no of course not is it the best way i
don't know but it was easy to implement
and it's working fine for us
so how do we use it this is another code
snippet they'll just go through very
quickly this is like the decision maker
that i talked about before so we have
the input decision maker and then the
camera control so for the input we do
several steps
we have like an
estimator which estimates where the area
of interest is based on all the player
coordinates we have some feature
producers as i just said
event producers decision rules
the other the last two are not really
important
and
basically the decision maker just
computes it calculates where the camera
should be aimed at
so we do that here
first we generate an
intermediate id which we can then use to
compute the total running time for the
decision maker from start to end and
we lock that it started so then we have
the the first time we actually have this
id and here i for example
we we compute this area of interest and
we also log this
so it locks the event logs the id it'll
lock some attributes
and basically this is done this is the
an example of the output i reformatted
it a little bit and i threw some things
out so it doesn't
overwhelm me with me still overwhelm
but
here we can actually see this event so
we have the decision maker which started
we have the the area of interest which
was determined then we have all these
attributes that we actually store here
what's also interesting i like this part
because here we have the attributes we
have the ball so this is actually the
the field coordinate of the ball so we
say the the absolute center is zero zero
so it's like a bit to the to the right
and a bit downwards
that's where the ball was actually at
and we can actually also see that here
one of our earlier
log events that the the yolo model
actually define it actually identifies
or detects this ball here
it's a vampire i think and now we have
some other events but this is not really
important one thing that is important is
the input id as i talked about before we
want to
monitor the full latency of the model so
we have to know when did an image come
in which image was it and how is it used
throughout the process so
somewhere before this we actually make
this
for example this input id
and then we say well
this input id so from this camera at
this timestamp we generated a frame or a
frame came in into our application
and then
we used specifically this frame idea
in this step
and that way we actually also know when
this frame id was used
last which is somewhere below here and
if you just compute like the timestamps
between those you have the full latency
of
the model of the full application
actually
so how do we use this
this is like the frame lifetime as i
discussed before and i i mentioned at
the beginning that we should have around
300 milliseconds
latency and what you can see here is
that completely filled during our first
attempts because well the in general is
around like one second which is not even
that bad but for some reason there's
this weird teal at the end where uh the
frame that we produce takes up to eight
seconds to be actually used in a camera
command and that's not really something
you want because then you get this
situation where you very nicely detect
the ball and the camera goes there but
by the time that we actually are there
the ball has been
already
like very far away so then we went about
debugging this
so the next step is to
what we did is check this this frame
lifetime over the time that the
application has been running what we
also see here is that it's
for some reason it is building up so the
longer the application ran
the longer it took
between the very start of a frame and
the
between when we actually use it in our
application and this is quite weird
and what we noticed
is that
the multi-processing queue
which
many people use
actually has a bottleneck of having like
a limited size in the queue itself
so here's a code snippet of how we
basically use this multi-processing
queue
so
we have the um the input part
so in the input part we put these frames
into a queue
and then we have the output part where
we
actually get them out of the queue
and the problem is we are putting frames
at a higher rate into the queue and out
of the queue so to solve this because
and we want to use the last frame every
time so at the output
we keep
pulling things out of the queue until
the queue is empty which is like right
here we have this try except block so
once the queue is empty
we stop pulling things out of the queue
and we start actually doing the
detections
however what we noticed is that um in
this multi-processing queue things do
not actually get put in the queue unless
there's room in a queue
so what we end up having is a situation
where we are putting 10 frames per
second into the queue but then the in
fact they end up somewhere before the
queue
and only after a while they are put into
the queue
and then we get this accept statement
every time because there's only one
thing in the queue
it's a bit of a complicated story
but the result was that we were using
over time older and older and older
frames so while the other parts of the
application were running quite nicely we
were just always using all data so how
did we solve this
we used a different type of queue and we
actually tested before of course if this
queue would be working and it was
i won't go into the details of this code
but it's basically
set mq 0mq is also a python package
which is able to handle larger amounts
of data more easily and it works
slightly differently but still you have
like this this
thing like a publisher which puts things
in the into the queue and then we have a
subscriber which takes things from the
queue and uses it in the rest of the
application
so afterwards
this wasn't very early on in our process
so we didn't even have a graphics card
yet so the times are still too high as
you can see but at least they weren't
building up over time so now they're
nicely around one second
there are some some exceptions but it's
not as in the image i showed before that
it actually builds up to like eight
seconds at the end of the
of the application runtime
and
lastly what we can also do with this
information is actually plot the latency
per event
so each event is one of those steps that
i talked about before like the decision
maker which produces features and stuff
like that here you can see that many of
the events that we have actually work
very fast they are they've like
i don't know like a 0.2 millisecond
delay and we should focus on the parts
which have a high delay so here it's
actually a part of the camera where we
ask it where the position is so where
it's currently at because we send like a
command oh we have to move that way but
while it's moving that way we are
already sending the new command but we
have to know where it is to know which
speed it needs which velocity it needs
for the other part
so
[Music]
we actually ask that like we ask where
are you currently at and we show here
that that's right now really a
bottleneck which is also a problem and
we're working on fixing that
that was basically what i wanted to say
if you have any questions please ask
thanks
[Applause]
any questions
[Music]
yeah so the the problem is not really
there we the the buffer there works
perfectly fine but then after
pre-processing the image you put it into
a new cue
until the yolo models are basically
ready to detect something else
because the yolo models do not run in
sync with the the video capture we
cannot get the yolo models to work at 25
frames per second
when you get the last new image
yes the most recent one so
you have to throw those those previous
images away somehow
yes you get the last i i get what you're
saying so you're saying uh if we just
yeah if you if you have those in a
combined sense then it works but we have
to
[Music]
we wanted to ensure that we can also use
this for other purposes
and in that case we may deal with
different input sources so we wanted to
decouple the input so for example the
camera source from the the detections so
there's a deep coupling point there pro
programmatically and that's why we put
like something in between and we just
use the cues before that because we've
worked with them often and they never
know
it's not i'm not trying to discuss
whether it's it's of course possible i
think
in the back yes
um yeah we do right now
because then you
still have to then we would have in the
detection like in the detectors we would
have to say well we're ready to now only
process the next frame so we have like a
feedback loop so that's why for now we
decided to just process every single
frame because the resizing and cropping
is not really something that's building
up a lot of latency
well i mean you already fixed the q
issues that's nice
but you said that you would need 25 fps
and what
processor are you using uh
yeah just to be clear so what i meant is
that if we have the yolo at 25 fps then
you do not need a queue in between
because we can just count yolo as like a
pre-processing step and you can just put
it right there
even then there are some things to keep
in mind but uh
but if it's not so it's lower than that
then we that's why we built view between
but your question is more like which
yolo model were using
hardware are or using to run
we have
[Music]
we have i don't know the cpu model or
type but for the gpu we have a rtx 38c
360 or 380 360 i think
yeah we do have a gpu right now and the
example like the latencies that i showed
before with like one second we didn't
have one yet but we've used one because
one second is just too high so we really
needed one
we have not yet
okay
it's something to look into one thing to
keep in mind is that we have to run
these for each camera
and also
we run separate models for the ball on
the player because we noticed that when
we tried to encapsulate them in one
model the performance for the ball
really dropped because the difference
between a foot and a ball is apparently
very difficult to detect for you though
not yet so we have currently once a test
set up in belgium we have been
which was
at the
european championships in amsterdam last
june
uh which was also the first time that we
experimented with the the
actually computer vision before that
with the players were trackers
um and there we the setup was also a bit
differently because we partnered with
the 5g up here we actually used a 5g
connection instead of a local server
but we are there's uh currently phil
being implemented in england and the
there should be a couple being
implemented in the upcoming month in
germany as well so we're also looking
into the
even more projectionalizing this and
having it
run simultaneously on multiple fields
i'm sorry i didn't quite catch that
oh yes definitely especially um if the
the distance from camera to field this
similar and also the pitch color is
similar the models work all right
and the player models generally work all
right regardless of which field it is
but if the
pitch pitch colors change so you have
also these blue fields in hockey we
really noticed the performance for the
ball dropping and also if the camera is
a lot further away it didn't seem to
actually be able to catch the ball so we
had to retrain quite a quite a few times
already
uh yeah well i think
we have we have um
considered it and i think we will be
implementing that as well but we we had
to actually up the accuracy for the ball
detector anyways before even considering
a comma filter because before if you
have you have it like
once every three
detections the kalman filter doesn't
really work you actually have it you
have to have it in successive frames but
it is something that will be interesting
to see
i'm from uh idol which is very
tiny timely written on my thing here
idol is accompanied by
[Music]
two entities so my own company why books
data science which i do together with
kunu is actually sitting there and also
by team tv and there's also someone from
team device sitting here
coincidentally also called schoon so
that's a bit confusing and we yeah we
set up this entity together
sports um there are other companies
which are doing this
also yes but the main difference between
those companies and ours is that they
use a system where they have like
four static cameras on the midline which
each film like a different part of the
pitch and then they stitch those
digitally together
and
well you have some advantages because
it's generally a bit faster because you
do not have to actually send the the pt
set
commands
we believe that our system will be
better because we can actually zoom as
well without losing any of the
resolution and stuff like that or having
to do difficult tricks there
yeah so indeed the the from this is more
business point of view but from the
business point of view indeed it's um
we target like the top segments for for
example field hockey the top segments
for soccer for football are not really
interesting right now because
well they have so much money why would
they need an automatic camera system and
i think before we actually have
something that works better than a human
cameraman will be
a while or never
it can
also
have multiple
the question is whether the decision
making is for a single camera or for
multiplication yeah so the decision
making is for all cameras at the same
time so it basically determines where
the interested interesting point is on
the field and then in the camera
controller i didn't show it here but in
the camera controller we can also
identify of or use rules per camera so
for example what we noticed is that if
we just
use the the field chord as is if the
ball or the players are somewhere like
far away from the camera it is really
tilted up very high because it tries to
have
the ball or the players in the middle of
the camera but then you have like a very
large amount of sky that you see so we
experiment with tilting it downwards and
that's of course different per camera
because yeah
thanks any other question
so you mentioned the events in the
corners right in the game
have you tried protecting any other
events like a goal for example what we
did before
beforehand i talked about like they had
these trackers so we didn't i can't
touch that of course
we had these trackers instead of using
uh like a computer vision to detect
players and we didn't have the ball yet
so we tried to do it just by having
those players and what we notice there
is that the middle of the players is
generally all right except in two
situations where they're moving very
fast like a counter-attack or um during
like the build-up phase so when they're
just passing around
at the back so we tried to build models
to detect that at some point which we
they were working all right i think but
uh once we could actually detect the
ball that's of course a way better
approximation for the the interesting
point of the field
well this is
that's a different
application but we're also
working on that
for tennis right now so we're trying to
detect events for tennis like the
forehand back and stuff like that but we
also want to implement this in other
sports as well so for hockey indeed if
you can detect the goal in a penalty
corner and like a quick attack with a
shot then it's already a very
interesting product i think
but the i think that will be a separate
application because
because
it will be a separate application
because it's not really necessary to do
that real time sure